does the sohcahtoa acronym refer to well
s stands for sign C stands for cosine
and the T here stands for tangent okay
so what the sine is it's a ratio and the
ratio is where you're comparing two
things as a fraction so what we're going
to do is we're going to take the sine of
an angle and what it equals it's the
opposite side over the hypotenuse
so this acronym helps you because it's
going to be the second letter divided by
the third so the opposite side over the
hypotenuse the cosine of an angle is the
adjacent side over the hypotenuse so you
can see a over H and then the tangent of
an angle equals the opposite side over
the adjacent side so you can see second
over third over a so these are called
trigonometric ratios and this is for
right triangles and I'll show you some
examples here so say we have this right
triangle ABC and we want to find the
sine of angle a so what that means is
it's the opposite side over hypotenuse C
over H and so if we're standing here so
we kind of have this perspective like
you're at this vertex this angle here
the opposite side you go across
diagonally so that's going to be five
okay the hypotenuse is the side that's
across from the right angle okay so
that's 13 so the sine of angle a the
ratio of the two sides the opposite and
the hypotenuse is 5 thirteenth's
okay now if we want to find the cosine
of angle a you can see we're going to do
the adjacent side over the hypotenuse
okay now adjacent means next to okay so
if you're here adjacent means next to
that's this side and this side we want
to use the 12 not the 13 the 13 is the
hypotenuse is to cross from the right
angle that's the longest side so when
they say adjacent don't pick the
hypotenuse pick the other one okay so
that's going to be 12 divided by the
hypotenuse adjacent over hypotenuse so
that's going to be 13 okay now the
tangent of angle a to let this angle
tangent is opposite over adjacent okay
so if you're here offices across
adjacent is next to so that's going to
be five twelfths
okay so far so good okay now let's go
over here to this angle
okay angle B so we're changing our
perspective we're at this vertex so the
sine of angle B is opposite okay so
we're going across so opposite which is
12 over the hypotenuse which is 13
okay the cosine of angle B is adjacent
so you can see here Jason is next to
five over the hypotenuse 13 five 13 and
the tangent of angle B is the opposite
side over the adjacent side okay so
that's gonna be 12 over 5 okay so this
is how you find the sine cosine and
tangent in a right triangle we only use
the two acute angles we don't use the
right angle so there's no sign of angle
C okay or cosine or tangent okay just
the two acute angles not the right angle
okay so let me show you how you use
these trig ratios in solving problems so
over here we have a right triangle you
can see the forty degree angle and we
want to solve for this missing side here
X so we have to ask ourselves as what
trig function ties together this single
this side and this side okay well let's
see if you're at this angle this is the
opposite side and this is the adjacent
side to this angle so we go to our
acronym so
Toa and you can see opposite and
adjacent that's the tangent ratio so
that's what we're going to use so we've
got the tangent of 40 degrees equals the
opposite over adjacent 5 divided by X
now you can cross multiply okay anything
divided by 1 is itself so you can cross
multiply and you get x times the tangent
of 40 equals 5 times 1 which is 5 then
all you have to do is divide by the
tangent of 40 okay on both sides and
this is an exact answer you can do that
on your calculator and you're gonna get
the length of this side now one quick
hint something that helps is that you
can switch these on the diagonal okay
when you have a proportion like this or
ratio you
the ratio you can actually switch these
so I could have saved myself a little
bit of time by putting X here and
tangent of 40 here and I would have had
it in one step okay let's go to the next
one so here you can see another right
triangle we've got 35 degrees and we
want to figure out what trig function
ties together the adjacent side and the
hypotenuse suits across from the right
angle that's the hypotenuse adjacent is
next to so that looks like cosine ties
together adjacent and hypotenuse so
we've got the cosine of 35 degrees
equals it's always going to be the
second letter over the third letter and
that acronym so x over 8 and then what
you can do is you can cross multiply x
times 1 is X 8 times cosine of 35 and
now you're ready to put that in your
calculator and get the length of this
missing side
okay last example I'll show you here is
a now we've got this angle 50 degrees
and we're trying to tie together the
opposite side so you across and the
hypotenuse across from the right angle
so that's going to be let's see opposite
and hypotenuse you can see that's going
to be sine Soh so right so sine of 50
degrees equals 4 divided by Y I'm going
to use that little technique I was
showing you earlier about switching
these on the diagonal okay so Y over 1
equals 4 divided by the sine of 50
degrees and this is an exact answer it's
ready to be put in your calculator and
you can get a decimal approximation for
the missing side so this is how you work
with right triangle trigger a she owes
and if you enjoy these videos go ahead
and subscribe to the channel and I look
forward to seeing in the next video